let's do one more homogeneous
differential equation or first order
homogeneous differential equation to
differentiate from the homogeneous
linear differential equations we'll do
later but anyway the problem we have
here it's
the derivative of y
respect to x
is equal to that x looks like a y
with respect to x is equal to
x squared
plus 3
y squared i'm writing it a little bit
small so that i'll run a space
divided by
2
x y so with all of these
homogeneous equations and obviously we
don't know if it's homogeneous yet so we
have to try to write it as a function of
y divided by x so it looks like we could
do that if we divide the top and the
bottom by x squared so if we just
multiply we need a different color
1 over x squared or x to the negative 2
over 1 over x squared right we're
essentially just multiplying by 1. and
then we get that is equal to what
1
plus
3
y squared over x squared
divided by
what is this 2
if you divide x divided by x squared you
just get a 1 over x so 2 times y over x
or we could just rewrite the whole thing
and we get this is just equal to 1 plus
3
y
over x
squared divided by 2 times y over x so
yes this is a homogeneous equation
because we were able to write it as a
function of y divided by x so now we can
do the substitution with v and hopefully
this is starting to become a little bit
of second nature to you so we can make
the substitution that
v is equal to
y over x or another way of writing that
is that y
is equal to
x v
and then of course d the derivative of y
with respect to x or if we take the
derivative with respect to x of both
sides of this that's equal to the
derivative of x is 1 times v this is
just the product rule
plus
x times the derivative of v with respect
to x
and now we can substitute the derivative
of y with respect to x is just this
and then the right hand side of the
equation is this but we could substitute
v for y over x so let's do that
and so we get
v plus
x instead of dv dvx i'll write v prime
for now just so that i don't take up too
much space
v prime is equal to
1 plus 3
v squared we're making the substitution
v is equal to y over x 3
v squared
all of that over 2 v
2 v now let's see what we can do this is
where we just get our put our algebra
hat on and try to simplify until it's a
separable equation in v
so let's do that so let's multiply both
sides of this equation by 2v
let's see we'll get
2v
squared plus 2 x
v
v prime right 2 v times that yep that's
2 x v v prime is equal to 1 plus
3 v squared now let's see let's subtract
2 v squared from both sides of this and
we will be left with
2
x
v
v prime
is equal to 1 plus
let's see we're subtracting 2 v squared
from both sides so we're just left with
a 1 plus v squared here right 3v squared
minus 2v squared just v squared
and let's see we want it to be separable
so let's put all the v's on the left
hand side
so we get
2
x v
v prime
divided by
1 plus
v squared is equal to 1.
and let's divide both sides by x
so we get the x's on the other side so
then we get
2
v
and i'll now i'll switch back to the
other notation instead of v prime i'll
write
dv
dx
2v times the derivative of v with
respect to x divided by 1 plus v squared
is equal to i'm dividing both sides by x
notice i didn't write the x on this side
so that is equal to 1 over
x
and then if we just multiply both sides
of this times dx where
we've separated the two variables and we
can integrate both sides so let's do
that
let's go up here i'll switch in a
different color so that you know i'm
doing working on a different column now
so multiply both sides by dx i get
2
v over 1 plus
v squared
dv
is equal to
1 over x dx and now we can just
integrate both sides of this equation
this is a separable equation with in
terms of v and x
and what's the integral of this at first
you might think oh boy this is
complicated this is difficult maybe some
type of some type of trig function but
you'll see that it's kind of just the
reverse chain rule
we have a a function here 1 plus v
squared an expression here we have its
derivative sitting right there
so the antiderivative of this and you
could make you could actually make a
substitution if you like you could say u
is equal to 1 plus v squared then d u is
equal to 2v dv and then well you'd end
up saying that the anti-derivative is
just the natural log of u or in this
case the anti-derivative of this is just
the natural log
the natural log of 1 plus v squared we
don't have to even write an absolute
value there because that's always going
to be a positive value so the natural
log of 1 plus
v squared
and just i just want to i mean i hope i
didn't confuse you i kind of that's how
i think about i say if i have a
expression and i have its derivative
multiplied there then i can just take
the antiderivative of the whole
expression and i don't have to worry
about what's inside of it so if this was
a 1 over an x or 1 over u it's just the
natural log of it so that's how i knew
that this was the antiderivative and if
you don't believe me use the chain rule
and take the derivative of this and
you'll get this and hopefully it'll make
a little bit more sense but anyway
that's the left hand side and then that
equals
that well this one's easy that's the
natural log
say the absolute value of x
plus we could say plus c but just so
that we can simplify it a little bit
an arbitrary constant c we can really
just write that as the natural log
of the absolute value of some constant c
right i mean this is still a some
arbitrary constant c so we can rewrite
this whole equation as
the natural log
of 1 plus
v squared is equal to when you add
natural logs you can essentially just
multiply the two numbers that you're
taking the natural log of
the natural log of we could say the
absolute value of cx
and so the natural log of this is equal
to the natural log of this
right
so we could say that 1 plus v squared is
equal to
cx
and now we can unsubstitute so we know v
is equal to y over x so let's do that
so we get 1 plus y
over x
squared is equal to c x
let me scroll this down a little bit
let's see let's multiply both sides of
this equation times x squared this yes
we could just this we could rewrite this
as y squared over x squared so we
multiply both times times x squared you
get
x squared
plus y
squared is equal to c x to the third and
we're essentially done if we want to put
all of the variable terms on the
left-hand side we could say that this is
equal to x squared plus y squared minus
c x to the third is equal to 0. and this
implicitly defined function or curve or
however whatever you want to call it is
the solution
to our original homogeneous first order
differential equation
so there you go
i will see you in the next video and now
we're actually going to do something
we're going to start embarking on
higher order differential equations and
actually these are more useful in some
ways easier to do than the homogeneous
and the exact equations that we've been
doing so far
see you in the next video